edan ancillary was the stereotypical
country bumpkin hailing from rural New
Zealand the shy gangly beaky ever
stepped out of the shadows to take on
one of the greatest physical challenges
of them all climbing the world's highest
mountain through guts grit and
determination he managed to as he
famously said knock the bastard off from
there he used his newfound fame as a
platform to improve the lives of the
Nepalese people who he had developed an
affinity for leaving behind a legacy
that endures beyond the record books in
today's by graphics we look at the life
and the accomplishments of the first
demands whoever climbed Mount Everest
Sir Edmund Hillary Edmonds Percival
Hillary was born on July the 20th 1919
in Auckland New Zealand shortly after
the birth of his father Percival or
Gustus was allocated a land grant in
recognition of his service during the
First World War as a results the family
which included three-year-olds June
moved south to the farming settlements
of tucao a younger brother Rex soon came
along June later described the three
boys as follows
ed had the brains Rex had the looks and
I was the girl
according to Ed's own recollections it
was his mother who held the family
together she managed the money man's
made sure that the kids were okay this
was no easy task
hillarie children had an adventurous
streak that saw them pushing everything
to the limit once said and Rex swapped
bicycles with Ed riding on the one that
was too small for him Rex however found
it hard to control the larger bike still
lowing the Ted would be chasing him he
went as fast as he could turning a
corner he collided with a car bouncing
off the bonnet and bouncing off the road
the driver was terrified that he had
killed Rex but ed was merely terrified
of the beating he knew his father would
give him when he saw the state of the
bike although Percy was a pacifist he
was prone to fits of Rage these bursts
of rage they were usually directed at
his oldest son even though he feared the
beatings the southern edge was
determined to never give his father the
satisfaction of admitting that he had
done anything wrong despite the
competitive bond with his brother Ed's
early years they were filled with
loneliness throughout his primary years
he didn't make any friends while other
kids were out playing he filled his time
with extra tuition which allowed him to
enter high school two years ahead of his
peers this only made his social
situation worse
so he was now shorter and younger than
all the other kids high school meant
that he had to take the train to the
prestigious Auckland Grammar School and
rubbed shoulders with the children of
the wealthy this intensified his lack of
self-confidence and social awkwardness
even further in his later years at often
recounted an incidents that occurred
during his first we could Auckland
grammar that had a deep impact on him he
turns up for his first gym class along
with his classmates the teacher surveyed
his new students and then fixing his
gaze on Edie said what have they sent me
he then went on to catalogue a long list
of what he saw was wrong with that
finally he told the humiliated boy to go
against the wall with the other misfits
ed recalls that this incidents marked
the beginning of a sense of inferiority
about his looks which would remain with
him to the rest of his life
Edie found the companionship that he
lacked with other humans in books after
wading through the typical teenage
literary attractions of the day such as
Edgar Rice Burroughs and H rider Haggard
he discovered books on Namsan Nehring as
they fascinated him and he devoured
everything on the subject that he could
get his hands on Percy ran the local
newspaper in the town and had a sideline
business as beekeeper in 1935 Ed's last
year at Auckland grammar the family
moved to the inner Auckland suburb of
Remer era beekeeping now became the
family's main source of income the
change meant that Edie no longer had to
spend hours on the train every single
day from college ed went on to the
University of Auckland's where he
studied mathematics and science he also
joins the university tramping club with
his long stride and his abundant stamina
he soon became a star bush Walker
he also took lessons in boxing and
jujitsu but head-to-head combat there
wasn't his style in 1938 at who had been
struggling academically drops out of
university and joined his father in the
beekeeping business his stamina
endurance and physical strength were
ideally suited for the job it was hot
physically demanding work and in the
summer he would carry out his duties
wearing only shorts a hat and a veil
every day he would have to endure up to
300 bee stings not long after Edie began
working on the bee farm his parents
converted to a New Age religious
movement called radiant living the group
had beliefs that were not far removed
from those of Christian Scientists and
and his brother Rex they soon became
converts to when war broke out in 1939
it appeared inevitable that both Hillary
boys would be drafted into the New
Zealand armed services but Percy the
pacifist was determined to prevent this
from happening he managed to get himself
and AD off the hook by relying on a
provision that allowed exemptions for
reserved occupations including
beekeeping however Percy did all of this
without telling ed who was not happy to
hear about his father's meddling Percy
soon discovered that only one exemption
per family was allowed its exemption
meant that Rex would have to go to war
it just so happens though that Rex
unlike Edie was a conscientious objector
Edie would have been happy to sign up a
but Rex wasn't he followed his conscious
and spent the next four years in a
detention camp for three years at fumed
silently than his father had prevented
him from fulfilling what he saw as his
patriotic duty
finally in 1944 he joins the Royal New
Zealand Air Force it was during his
training as a flight navigator in New
Zealand's South Island that Ed
encountered towering mountains imagine
yet in a few solo climbs then he came
across the 2884 metre snow-capped mounts
Tappahannock ooh he became determined to
make an ascent and arranged for a
three-day leave he arranged to climb the
mountain with a partner but the man
pulled out at the last minute had
decided to go it alone with a friend
taking him a part of the way on his
motorbike he then walked 8 kilometers to
a farm where he stayed overnight the
next day he walked another 24 kilometers
overnight it is another farm and then
set off up the mountain he reached the
top without any trouble and he returned
safely the next day he walked another 32
kilometres before receiving a lift and
was delighted with this first experience
he had knocked off his first mountain
and it felt great
[Music]
returning to his war service it found
himself stationed to the Pacific Islands
years later he would recall coming
across the small Fijian boy who came up
and begged for a piece of Brett
experiences like this form the catalyst
for his great humanitarian work that he
would pursue later in life
Edd's he never came near combat though
he did contract malaria his war also
nearly ended in disaster when a full
petrol tank in his plane fell and burst
into flames the plane came down into the
ocean before aired who was not wearing a
shirt could jump clear of the blazing
craft a wave knocked him off his feet
and he fell into the flames he then
managed to roll off the plane and into
the sea
Edie suffered second-degree burns and
the pain was made worse by him having to
swim 450 meters and then walk 800 meters
under the Blazing Sun before he reached
help he was taken to a hospital in
Guadalcanal where he was shot full of
morphine and antibiotics he was told
that he would be in bed for months
before he could achieve a full recovery
however within two weeks he was up and
walking about he became so restless and
so bored that he begged his doctors to
allow him to recover at home in Auckland
they finally relented and he was
discharged from the Air Force and sent
home when I got home he didn't intend to
lie rounds but rather get to work for
when he discovered that his father had
taken on other workers and said no
opening for him on the bee farm he moved
to the South Island in search of new
opportunities he joins the New Zealand
Alpine Club and over the next couple of
years he learns the climbers craft as he
took on many of the mountainous peaks of
the South Island EDD climbs with others
but he always wanted to be the first to
the top in 1949 older sister June got
married Percy had enjoyed an especially
good honey season and he paid for head
to travel with his parents to Europe
Eadie took every opportunity to take on
European peaks including the Eiger
[Music]
while he was in Europe had received a
letter from a former climbing partner by
the name of George Lowe informing him
that plans runned away of a New Zealand
party to undertake a track of the
Himalayas they intended to explore the
possibility of tackling the world's
highest peak Mount Everest something
that had never been done successfully
before no he wants you to know whether
Hillary was interested the answer well
as he might imagine it was an
unequivocal yes in mountaineering terms
there was no greater challenge than a
successful ascent of Mount Everest which
towers 8,848 meters from the ground many
climbers had died trying to get there
most famously the British climber George
Mallory in 1924 a turning point in the
history of attempts on Everest occurred
in 1950 when the Nepalese government
agreed to allow parties to attempt the
mountain from Nepal on the southern side
previous expeditions had attacked from
Tibet on the northern side of the
mountain the Nepalese government decided
to let a different country every year
have a go it just so happens that in
addition to the New Zealand group a
party of British climbers were also
planning an assault on Everest the
British group sent a letter to the New
Zealanders suggesting that they join up
the invitation however was only for two
climbers the question was now well who
would go after some heated discussion it
was decided that adds the acknowledged
superior climber and Earl Ritter furred
would be the token New Zealanders on the
British expedition rather than a
concerted effort to reach the summit
this expedition was more of an
exploratory probe while climbing with
Shipton the expedition leader Hillary
came across a vast Hidden Valley that
appeared to provide a previously unknown
route to the top the group split up and
agreed to return the next year the
following year in 1952 however was
assigned to a Swiss expedition attempts
to climb Everest the British with in New
Zealand contingent that have to wait
until 1953
[Music]
planning the 1953 assault began in a
small office in London it was led by
Eric Shipton who believed that the
journey should be made by a small team
with basic supplies but Shipton had only
just begun choosing his team when there
was a sudden change of plan
previous attempts to climb Everest by
small teams had failed it was decided
that this time they would use a big team
with the latest equipment and plenty of
supplies a new leader John Hunt was
appointed in March of 1953 the
expedition team began to arrive in
Kathmandu the team got ready to make
their way east to the Himalayas and
Mount Everest Hillary was one of 14
climbers in more than 30 Nepalese
Sherpas who made up the team nearly 400
people set off from Kathmandu on March
the 10th more than 350 of them were
locals who are hired to carry supplies
to the site for the first camp for 17
days they walked through the Nepalese
countryside until they arrived base camp
then they stayed for three weeks
planning the climbs to come they
practiced with their climbing gear on
local cliffs and tried to get used to
the thin air of the high mountains in
early April base camp was moved from
near tengboche monastery to a second
main base the lake camp higher up by a
lake on a glacier
the first big challenge for the leaders
came on April the 13th for men including
Hillary were selected by hunt to explore
a region known as the Khumbu Icefall
this was an area of house sized blocks
of ice that cracked and creaked the
climbers had to find a safe route for
the Nepalese Sherpas who were to follow
bringing supplies a number of camps were
set up through the ice for the lead
climbers pressed through the Khumbu
Icefall and set up advanced base camp
above it by now Hillary had impressed
all with his boundless energy and
exceptional strength early on in the
morning of April the 26 had teamed up
with Sherpa Tenzing Norgay for the first
time their task was to reach an advanced
camp that was set up during the previous
year's Swiss expedition roped together
the two men waited through deep slushy
snow that had shortened with the sun's
rays despite being hot and thirsty the
pair worked well together arriving at
the camp they found an unexpected treat
the Swiss had left behind some supplies
which included delicious cheese on the
way back to base camp Hillary boasted to
Norgay that he could make it back within
an hour all went well until he decided
to leap across a crevasse he reached the
other side but the edge of the crevasse
broke off suddenly he was slipping
and his fate was in the hands of his
partner fortunately Norgay was a
brilliant climber he quickly grabbed
ahold of the pole and used all of his
skill strength and experience to help
Hillary climb up to the side of the
crevasse
returning to base camp the bonds between
the two men had been strengthened by
Hillary's narrow escape
Hillary wrote to his parents that he and
Norgay had become the Tigers of the
campaign on that day they had shown
strength courage and fearlessness and
they hoped that that would take them to
the top of Everest by late made the lead
climbers had scaled the lots a face to
the south called a flat area that is one
of the nastiest places on Everest here
they set up their seventh camp this was
where they would make their final push
to the summit two other climbers were
selected to make the first push but they
only made it to the lower South Summit
[Music]
on the morning of May the 28th five more
climbers set off from the South Col
three lead climbers were there to cut
steps for the two men who had been
picked to go all the way to the top
hillary and tenzing by nightfall the
helpers it turns back and now it was up
to the two of them Hillary and Tenzing
pitched their tents below Everest south
summit on an uneven ice ledge at 6:30
a.m. on May the 29th they began their
final journey to the summit while
climbing a steep slope the surface snow
shifted carrying Hillary with it then
with their oxygen running low the two
men came to a rock face it was too
slippery to try and climb Hard Rock in
the crampons fitted to their boots they
had to find another way hillary saw a
cornice attached to a rock it had
started to come away leaving a crack
stretching upwards between the rock and
the ice he crawled into the crack and
grasping the rock in front of him he
pulled himself further in grabbing his
crampons into the ice he pulled himself
through the crack at the top of the
cornice and signaled to Norgay to follow
they now continued along the ridge
hoping the summit would come into view
just as Hillary doubted if they could go
on he looked up and saw a snowy peak
that dropped away on all sides Hillary
and self later recalled a few more
whacks of the ice axe a few more weary
steps and we were on the summit it was
now time to celebrate to take
photographs and appreciates the best
view in the world the news that Everest
had finally been conquered reached the
outside world on between the seconds IDI
was lionized as the beekeeper from rural
New Zealand who had done the impossible
from Nepal he flew to London where he
was appointed a knight commander of the
British Empire by the newly crowned
Queen Elizabeth the second he returned
to New Zealand as a conquering hero
with thousands flooding the streets to
get a glimpse of him for the awkward and
shy young man that he was this
unexpected adulation it was hard to get
used to a few months after conquering
Everest Hillary made another conquest he
won over and married Louise Mary Rose
this time however he needed help he was
so shy that he had to rely on his
mother-in-law to propose on his behalf
this union later produced three children
Peter
Sarah and Belinda Peter would become a
climber just like his father reaching
the summit of Everest himself in 1990
both Hillary and Tenzing continued
climbing with Hillary tackling ten more
Himalayan peaks over the next decade on
January the 4th 1958 he led an
expedition to Antarctica following the
route of Robert Falcon Scott in 1912 the
New Zealanders became the first to make
the track in motorized vehicles with
Edie
riding a tractor Hilary later became an
unofficial ambassador for New Zealand in
the 1970s he commentated on several nu
Antarctic sightseeing flights on
November the 28th 1979 he was booked to
work on flight 901 but had to renege due
to other work commitments that flight
crashed into a mountain in Antarctica
with everyone on board being killed as
the years went by
Hillary returned increasingly to Nepal
then he became absorbed in programmes of
fundraising and building work for
sharper communities in 1960 he
established the Himalayan trust which
was responsible for the building of many
schools and hospitals throughout a
remote Himalayan areas Hilary received
terrible news though in 1975 tragedy
struck with his wife and daughter
Belinda being killed in a plane crash
while flying to join him in Nepal
devastated Hilary immersed himself in
his building work however this was
becoming increasingly difficult as he
was getting more and more altitude sick
Hillary's health deteriorated in the
late 1990s on January the 11th 2008 his
heart it finally gave out he died at the
Auckland City Hospital from cardiac
arrest his country they went into
mourning at a state funeral was held on
January the 22nd two months later a
thanksgiving service was held in his
honor
at some George's Chapel in Windsor
Castle standing guard outside the chapel
with Gurkha soldiers from Nepal showing
their respect for a man who had given so
much to improve the lot of that people
so I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographic
if you did there's a couple of things
you could do right now one is hit that
like button below also if you want more
stuff like this we put out brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday won't put out a new
video also if you want to watch
something else right now stuff from the
archive over there on the right and as
always thank you for watching